hello everyone and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong I am back it's your
girl Jacqueline alongside my favorite
person to talk movies with Mr Mark Ellis
oh well thank you Jaclyn but I
specifically asked for this specific
podcast to be referred to as Mark the
prince of fire the prince of the leader
of the Fire Nation and we'll redeem
myself in My Father's Eyes Can I pretend
that I'm in an avatar in this regard
because I feel like uh it is just the
body existing without the brain it's at
that point of the awards season oh okay
well so you were just at the Critics
Choice Awards as we're filming this
episode and that I've never been to the
Gayla I am so enthralled by the
celebrities that have to mingle with
critics and that awkward dance it is a
dance it kind of it must be like kind of
walking on eggshells right because
nobody wants to upset everybody they're
happy to take pictures with everyone
they don't want a bag with you in a
future movie seems like there's a lot of
uh nervous energy it's like a sixth
grade dance we're like the guy guys are
over here and the girls are over here
and nobody really wants to interact but
you got to go through the motions I
would say this it's always the case at
these shows where people don't know if
they're winning before they get there oh
any of the shows like the AFI honors
where they're just like celebrating
everybody in the room or the Alaska
which is like the Los Angeles Film
critics where they decide who wins
before you show up all of those are
great because they go in there knowing
they want yeah and so you don't really
have to deal with that sort of like
nervous energy I will add that the group
that is the Critics Choice adds a lot
more nervousness and a lot more energy
to all those things very similar to our
guests we have today although I wouldn't
say nervous I would say whirly energy
she brings worldly energy which is one
of the three members that do that that's
of course Steph Sabra one third of the
World Girls is back with us today to
talk about a movie that let me just go
ahead and say I think this is one where
we're gonna have some interesting
opinions but Steph welcome back to us
I'm so happy to be back yes interesting
is a really good word for it of course I
want to talk about the fact that Mark I
said that he has fire energy because of
course we're talking about The Last
Airbender the fire the earth and the
water everything in between five percent
rotten on the Tomato Meter back in 2010
with a 30 audience score the reason why
we're talking about it this week is
because we have knock at the cabin out
in theaters everywhere February 3rd this
is of course M Night shyamalan's latest
effort now as he's working with smaller
budgets and if you haven't checked it
out already please check out our ranking
of all of M Night shyamalan's movies
that was a really great episode we had
Alex Wolf on there also headed over to
rotten tomatoes.com because the last
airbender is on our 100 worst movies of
all time
yeah I mean we're celebrating and we're
shading all in the same boat I don't
know Mark I I do have to start with you
though
do you do you want the like do you want
to have the sort of like honor of saying
first and foremost what is happening
with the Last Airbender or would you
rather just tell me first and foremost
if it's wrong I'm gonna let you think
about it Jack but there's been a lot of
movies and a lot of media a lot of
creativity a lot of Endeavors that have
involved Earth and wind and fire none
better than the band Earth Wind and Fire
I mean let's Boogie Wonderland September
come on all-time great 70s band and then
I feel like they influenced all of this
art that we're talking about now does
whether you're talking about Avatar from
James Cameron where they're talking
about The Last Airbender Earth Wind and
Fire pretty cool
this movie has some redeeming qualities
that I did note that I did not really
look at in a positive light upon my
initial screening when I saw this movie
back in 2010. I think that Rotten
Tomatoes is
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I think the
audience is closer to right okay so I
think it's bad it's definitely a rotten
movie not a good flick but is it five
percent rotten those are for like you
know your leprechaun sixes you're that I
think that is unfair to leprechaun sex
wow I agree okay well that was one where
he went back to the hood and I agree
because that was funny I think well let
me think that may have been five no I
think it was five yeah I think that was
five anyway uh Steph real quick also I I
think I know where you stand on this
because we were talking a little bit in
the Green Room this is a movie that I
really do feel ended friendships so I
asked this very carefully what do you
feel about the last Ender is it right or
wrong I think the score is Right which
is hard for me to say because I never
don't it's so hard for me not to like a
movie but this movie made me feel like a
scrooge for the first time and like I
couldn't look at myself in the mirror
being like I hate something so much like
it made me not like myself so therefore
I don't like it wow we've never had
Miser stuff on the show before wow I I
thought you were going to defend this
movie simply because of your love of
Jackson Rathbone who was in Twilight
yeah I was trying to look for the
connection here and I'm like wait a
minute we know how much stuff supports
and Steph even won me over yeah with
Twilight a little bit when she's like no
you gotta watch Twilight like you're a
high school girl and that's what you're
going through so a lot of the stuff is
elevated yeah that argue that's not
going to apply to The Last Airbender no
it simply can't it simply can't today
man putting my foot down Jackson I will
say he was giving what Austin gave
before Austin Butler gave it that's all
I will say okay that is all I will say
for those that know they know it's like
a wintry Elvis in this movie
I'm sorry I didn't want to get into it
but he's he does whatever he does he's
doing the best he does here and in the
Twilight movies let me just say that
like him like sex appeal wise this is
the cutest he's looked all right the the
sexiness of not only Jackson rapper but
also that name my God you know he's the
fifth of his name really yeah and why
would you change the name I guess like
he's got a first name that's not Jackson
but then the middle name is Jackson and
you know when you have like a cool first
name kind of like M Night Shyamalan yeah
Jackson Rathbone pretty good but you
cannot evade the question anymore
Jacqueline Coley I tennis it back to you
I just Rotten Tomatoes wrong about the
Last Airbender I'm gonna go ahead and
say that it's I hate saying this again
but yeah it's wrong but not I'm more of
along your lines I would even say that I
could put this in a generous 35 maybe
even a 40 straight up look at you I
really could for different reasons just
I will get to that in a minute because
this is the thing I will say about this
movie do I think it's a well-made movie
no but I feel watching it the way some
people feel watching Black Adam what did
you you expect okay it's a kids movie
based on an anime based you know what I
mean like this was not something I was
going into with like any Animated Series
where they can like freak out and the
eyes get big and they do the like like
anything like that I can't take too
seriously when they do it as a live
action me personally I don't know maybe
I like some of those arguments because
maybe you picked the wrong director for
this task maybe there were some casting
issues that kind of you know there's
some white Washington in this movie
there's a whole lot of stuff like behind
the camera there's a whole lot of stuff
when you're watching the movie I think
we can all agree it's not the best movie
no but once we get into movie talk I
have some some interesting thoughts that
I now I'm in the position of trying to
win Steph over yeah oh yeah of being
it's not bad and I'm okay with this
because I'm never in this position so I
really love that all of that is coming
towards you like we're all like Trading
Spaces right now I'm ready to be
convinced also I will say this is the
one movie where I feel me and you are in
the dangerous position by not just
abjectively thinking it's awful but
we're on thin ice yeah but tell me
literally tell this is synopsis because
I think that will clue folks in who
haven't seen it just how out of pocket
we are for not calling it basically a
regurgitation all right kid so you got
your Earth Kingdom right you got your
Fire Nation you got your air Nomads and
you got your your water tribe and they
deal with ice a lot too so you have
these four different elements and the
people that represent these elements and
kind of uniting this all together into
one nice bundle like the force would be
an airbender and they're sort of the
ones that find the balance with
everything and so we have this land and
it was all peaceful and everything was
good and then the Airbender went away in
a period of darkness and conflict and
turn my own Strife came over the land
and now it appears that the Airbenders
re-emerge but not everybody's happy to
see this person because there's such a
struggle for power and there has been
for so many decades that now it's like
the the Fire Nation wants the Airbender
and they want to take over and then you
have the water people they're just
trying to figure their way Earth Kingdom
being like what happened to this kid and
we also have and I cannot stress this
enough
um APPA the flying dog that it may be
technically it's a bison yeah arguably
the best flying mammal since Falcor yeah
yeah I say that with all due respect to
Air Bud but I mean totally this puppy
can seriously move and so apple one of
the highlights of this movie and this
was the first of a Trilogy of films that
we ended up not getting even though the
movie made money we'll talk about all
that later there's your synopsis of The
Last Airbender I really love it and the
fact that you resisted to call him
Falcor I appreciate that because that is
all I got first time I was like okay
they've got their foul course again
Falcor is a dog I believe yeah I like
Dragon he's like oh yeah
bison I mean yes but it's still like the
idea of like the flying magical creature
that's really fun they bred a bison with
a uh with some sort of sheepdog like I'm
like this is this is still the vibe I
want the puppies I want the puppy I want
a bunch of little puppies flying around
uh before we get into all that we
definitely have to take a two minute
transition to our favorite review
creation manager Mr Tim Ryan why don't
you take it away sir favorite segment
two minutes with Tim
[Music]
with the success of The Sixth Sense
unbreakable and signs and right
Shyamalan carved out a niche as one of
big Studio Hollywood's most distinctive
voices but the reaction to his next
three films The Village Lady in the
Water and The Happening were a mix of
bemusement confusion or out and out
hostility still it's hard to overstate
just how scathing the reaction was to
The Last Airbender in 2010. fans of the
anime series felt it completely missed
what was great about the original it's
brilliantly drawn characters it's visual
inventiveness it's good humor and it's
philosophical depth and both fans and
newcomers critics and audience members
found fault with its whitewashed cast
its incomprehensible plot and its muddy
special effects but even if the Last
Airbender was a huge bomb it's nice to
report that Shyamalan is solidly rebound
in recent years if for no other reason
that he follows his Muse and takes
chances with original or at least non-ip
material which is still a rarity in
Hollywood that might have been one of
the reasons for the last airbender's
failure that he was adapting an existing
franchise
The Last Airbender is rotten at five
percent on the Tomato Meter with 192
reviews and it has a 30 audience score
and for comparison avatar The Last
Airbender the series which ran from 2005
to 2008 has an overall score of 100
percent
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Roger Eber of the Chicago
Sun Times wrote The Last Airbender is an
agonizing experience in every category I
can think of and others still waiting to
be invented the laws of chance suggest
that something should have gone right
not here however in a fresh review
Stephanie zakarak of movieline wrote The
Last Airbender for all its Shyamalan
style grandiosity is completely harmless
and inoffensive and at the very least
Shyamalan appears to be having a little
fun here the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus reads The Last Airbender
squanders its popular Source material
with incomprehensible plotting horrible
acting and detached to joyless Direction
so that's the last airbender and to end
things on a positive note we covered the
sixth sense and my chamelan's best
reviewed film on a previous episode of
the podcast so be sure to check that one
out as well back to you folks yeah that
was a fun episode of uh of rta's wrong
when we just kind of went down the
Shyamalan yeah lineage and I'm currently
working on I think it's going to be out
in maybe a month or maybe three weeks uh
and might Shyamalan movie versus nice so
I've like watched his entire filmography
again and like I I always loved this
dude I always love the way he makes
movies I love when you just have a
director who has a movie and it's an
event I felt so bad when like he kind of
went downhill and everybody was bashing
on him you know being included I didn't
like some of the movies but I was just
so happy to see the Resurgence after
this after after Earth and then we get
the visit and then I'm just I'm back on
the train ready for a knock at the cabin
I'm sugar coating what we just heard
okay real quick I would love your your
quick hit thoughts on listening to
because I again Tim takes us back to a
thing that we kind of forget I forget
the vitriol in some of these reviews
like people came out with knives what
did you think about this listening to
the critics like kind of go back because
again this was a movie it was it was
hated in a way that honestly we haven't
felt since after Earth which was the
next time he pissed people off this bad
I felt really seen and heard I I feel
completely understood because I remember
watching the Animated Series back in
2005 when it came out and at that time I
even knew as an anime fan like the
live-action adaptions are almost always
terrible and so when the movie came out
I remember like everyone like really
really hating it and I was like a child
I shouldn't know hate like that but I
really I really really knew it so I
really understood some of that it was
like why did you why'd you do that yeah
why'd you do that I mean this is the
thing it's the craziest thing in the
world is it seems like everyone involved
in this killed themselves to make this
incredibly bad movie but we will get
into all of that as we cue into movie
talk
[Music]
so this Keys into it because again the
the anticipation was high if I could
take people back to like before this
movie was released what was crazy about
it is for as much as people were like I
don't know about it because everybody
involved in the series was kind of like
I don't know about it because there's
already whisperings that this was not
going to be what the show was like and
they were already like I don't know even
despite that it was a huge event I
remember last airbender was on
everything it was like the merchandising
thing and so when it got this reception
of five percent do you think it was just
like people coming back for it or do you
do you feel like any of that hype like
played into it yeah I think people
definitely were hyped about it and I
think when you love a franchise so much
you want to believe in it you're like
well I'm gonna see it because they
probably didn't see what I would see and
then you would go to see it like I went
to see it everyone I knew when to see it
and we at that time I I don't know if I
was like checking for scores like that
but I remember everyone being like oh no
it says bad as they said it was did you
feel it instantly after the first time
you watched it yes yeah like within
minutes of it started the opening scene
I remember being like wait that's the
pronunciation of the Saka I'm just the
same exact way this was the early days
of shmos
it was me and Christian harloff and we
had our guest reviewer was a comedian
who one of the funniest people on Earth
Steve Simone and he's not only one of
the funniest people he's one of the
nicest human beings like if if you have
a bad day he's like I'm gonna pray for
you like like he goes to church three
times a week he left within 10 minutes
I can't do this I can't do this and he
just walked around the Grove Chris and I
sat there I think we stuck it out but I
remember like just like Steph I had my
popcorn ready because I was so excited
for this movie because of M night shyam
one I knew virtually nothing about
Avatar The Last Airbender leading into
this I had never seen the the anime so
I'm just like thinking okay we were
talking about Steph Curry right before
the cameras rolled right great Shooters
continue to shoot even after they miss
so invite Shaman he hits his first three
buckets maybe his first four buckets if
you count the village and then he starts
missing but Lady in the Water okay it
was a nice movie for his kids you know
George Lucas can go do radio land
murders if he wants just for fun yeah
and then he did the happening and it's
like oh boy what are we really getting
into here yeah maybe he was trying to
make a swacky b movie this was gonna be
the comeback this was gonna be the big
three that he drained that reminded
everybody exactly who this MFR was and
it just fell so flat in every phase of
the game when I was watching it the
acting seemed terrible it seemed joyless
to me and sometimes movies need to be
joyless Manchester sister by the Sea
needs to be joyless okay there's a lot
of sadness in that movie here I
understand that there's despair going on
in this land but it just seems like
nobody wants to have any fun I mean we
gotta find bison yeah and we're not
having any fun in this until I said
mandvi shows up as the main villain and
he's having a little bit of fun he's
having a little bit of fun you know I
like when villains have fun I wouldn't
say that this is the problem with what
happened with Dev patellas because he
was not having fun and he was the main
villain throughout it but it's because
it seemed the only direction that M
Night gave him was shout more like
there's a good character Arc in so many
of these characters that just gets like
drowned out but I think just bad
production but I do agree with you this
was supposed to be M night's comeback I
wanted to go back and look at it but do
you remember this about it how did you
feel about the three prior I just want
to start with this The Happening lady in
the water in the village because that
was the beginning of M Night like sort
of Dipping off what did you feel about
those three coming into this was M night
even a factor at all yeah I liked those
fine and I thought that this would be
like a cool take on the series on the
series I was like okay maybe it will be
more serious like his other films but
that's okay if they really commit to
that tone but the movie committed to no
tone really it was just serious and then
the when they tried to make it funny it
was like truly cringe-worthy and you can
see like you know you can see the the
sort of through lines of like Classic
Entertainment and and mythology in this
movie where you have the the sun who's
just turned evil because he's just so
hell-bent on Revenge and trying to
redeem himself somehow I do love the
uncle character I think Sean tube is the
best performer in this movie because the
uncle is like sort of sympathetic but
he's also like hey dude you really don't
have to like live up to anything we can
just like go you know fish for the rest
of our life yeah some Dimension yeah I
would I still think Dev Patel's giving
is all in this I just wish he had better
direction for it because again I think
we all know that Dev Patel is a very um
talented actor what I love about this is
the m night shyamal on Mythos literally
this was the movie where the emperor had
no clothes because there was like hints
of it and even signs people had like
some iffy things about signs remember
like they were mad about the
extraterrestrials who were semi-allergic
to water exactly came to a planet the 70
water I can defend that yeah so there
was like little there was little ticks
on like how this guy did things was to
service his ideas more than the
disservice and audience and we kept
getting little hints of that leading up
to everything until we get to this one
and it's like does this guy even know
how to operate a camera and that was the
thing that I think was in these reviews
it was people looking back at him and
being like we have hyped this guy up and
really it's just because he cribbed
Hitchcock better than anyone in his
first movie and that's the sixth sense
but that's also the question that I have
about any Studio that's going to put a
150 million dollar budget behind a movie
where it's like I know M Night Shyamalan
was one of the biggest director names
out there at the time yeah but it's
almost like you're hiring Alfred
Hitchcock to do The Lego Movie movie
it's like no you can find somebody
better Rod Serling isn't going to be the
right guy to tell the story of the
moomins this is what's so funny about
this is this is where I can picture you
know I love these tick tocks really like
we're going to take you inside of this
board meeting I can picture the exact
meeting I can picture them pitching it
well they're gonna come for us if we
don't get a brown guy to direct it I'm
sorry that is literally the only reason
why you make M Night Shyamalan direct
this and that might be predicated on hey
we want to cast white people as the
leads right thank you thank you and
change the name so it sounds a little
bit more exotic exactly like we're gonna
have to make this really white people
friendly we gotta have what we think is
our guy in the chair trying to execute
it and I love this now because I think
that if there were two directors who
should have spoke before they decided to
do what they do it's Chloe Zhao and M
Night Shyamalan for different reasons
because I feel like what happened to him
was like the opposite of what happened
to her she had all this Goodwill that
kind of evaporated because she was
trying to appease two people and he had
some Goodwill but a lot of doubters and
he was trying to like placate both in
this huge Disney machine and that's why
this film just looks absolutely horrible
and it was also kind of a I guess in
retrospect because I never knew this as
as somebody who came to the anime late
which I saw like over the pandemic I
watched and I thought it was great but
the producer the creators of that
Michael and Brian they're like okay well
you're making a big budget movie I think
that they were kind of like are we gonna
direct this yeah this is gonna be really
good at directing this yeah and then I
think that there ended up being some
sort of like conflict between them and M
night as far as like the vision of how
the movie should play out and that's a
real bummer when it's like you're you're
a baby and it's just kind of it gets it
not stolen but it's like everybody made
a lot of money this movie ended up
making money this movie did end up
making money 320 million dollars
worldwide it was not a flop which is so
crazy but again I think everyone knew
fool me once they knew they couldn't go
back like they knew with this team they
knew with this Vision with the actors
first of all none of the actors wanted
to come back because they were all
getting roasted for doing this like they
all like the arazzi nomination does hit
people in a way that they don't want to
be in it but I will ask you well do you
think at the time that sorry I want to
like reword this a little bit better
do you feel that it's inherently I don't
want to like say this do you feel it's
inherently because people enjoyed the
series first or is it because they
couldn't let it go were you a fan of the
series do you feel like the legacy is in
any way influencing what you have or did
you even have any like ideas on it I
think a hundred percent the Legacy and
the love of the series is What affected
it because everyone was like uh this was
people's introduction to anime who don't
watch anime especially in the states and
it had such good lore which I think they
tried to touch on in the movie but they
if you watched a movie they try if you
watch a series they tried to make the
movie the season one in one movie which
is like 26 episodes or something like
that so they're just like cutting story
lines and filling it with Exposition and
there's just no dialogue or character
you fall in love with the characters in
the show and then this it's like who are
these people yeah yeah what are you guys
even talking about yeah and it's it's a
weird thing to have this movie come out
and I compared to something like
Warcraft yeah that Duncan Jones did
where you have two armies that you
really have to please right you have the
hardcore Warcraft players then you also
are it's a big budget movie so you need
to get a lot of butts and seats not just
the warcraft folk you need to please a
the mass populous and that movie I think
was okay
both of those it did a much better job
you did a better job than Airbender but
Last Airbender the problem with it was
that it alienated people who were fans
and people like me who were newbies just
watching they said well this movie's
just terrible like there's very little
Redemption to it and again I I watched
it a couple of times this past weekend
yeah just trying to find the positivity
I did I mean I I love shyamahan and I I
think the actors were giving it their
all and this is when you talk about the
whitewashing in this movie this is not a
situation where it's like some famous
white performer who's like I want to do
this property these are kids that are
hired to do a job right barely like one
of them was hired because his her dad
was the producer and that's how they got
their money that is a very literally
it's not it's not Noah Ringer right no
ringer shows up to an audition he's he's
all of what nine or ten years old he's
already an expert at taekwondo when he
does it and and that's what he does now
I think he dislike he runs terrible
organizations and he does Taekwondo he
teaches kids so it's like he actually
had some chops he's just he's not the
one that forced it upon people so I
blame the folks behind the scenes on
doing that and can you imagine I mean
the vitro this movie got in 2010 with a
progressive Society we have in 2023 this
movie comes out now it probably gets
canceled before the word jump they
wouldn't do it now because yeah it
didn't make any sense because yeah the
girl the the girl that's like you know
the Boston saying yeah where she's just
like oh theme I mean her and this table
have a lot in common as far as acting
range and this is a table made of wood
and she's like the coolest girl
character in the series like seriously I
think she's fighting sexism but she's
also like a girly girl and she like
loves fighting and does she has so much
Dimension and she like jokes around and
a series and this was just like one tone
One Tone and very like more Damsel in
Distress and like I don't understand
that like anything deserved to be in
this particular story which I thought
was crazy she's married to book uh
Brooklyn Becker Brooklyn
um uh Beckham I want to say Becker
Brooklyn Beckham now so that is a nepo
baby Inception right there yeah they're
gonna have the biggest Beckham and
Victoria Beckham's kid is Brooklyn yeah
who is married to do they have five kids
not yet are they are they after age
burrow uh no their names these are kids
Brooklyn Bronx Manhattan Queen Brooklyn
Cruz Romeo Harper and another one I
don't I I had a thing for Beckham anyway
um but this is this is the whole thing I
would say about it is everyone involved
in it regretted it immediately in fact
Dev Patel had his inside the actor
Studio a couple years ago when he talked
about this where he was like at the time
I thought I was doing what everyone
expected me to do to be a part of these
things and like think about it now when
you have somebody like Jake Gyllenhaal
who's filmed like 80 million movies but
he comes on the set of Spider-Man no way
home and he's like I don't know how to
do this and this was back when they were
learning how to do this these big green
screen Productions like this that were
like becoming Commons place the 20s and
the 20 the 2010s and the early 2000s is
when that happened we didn't have movies
like this where people were acting to
balls like this is just past the
prequels I thought you were gonna
reference another Jake Gyllenhaal movie
where it's like I guess this is what
people expect me to do and that would be
the Prince of Persia true same where
it's like the guys giving it is all but
should you be the Prince of Persia I
don't know that was more practical
though just remember the prince of purge
he's fighting sand like running around
their swords but it's mostly him like
doing practical stunts with this one
when you think about like Dev Patel's
job for half the movie is standing in a
dark room like Gargamel talking about
I'm coming to get you my pretties like
this is not he was like kylo Ren he
walks so kylo Ren could run very that
and this is what's so funny with kylo
Ren it works because you get somebody
like they did it right they got the
right actor in the sense that you want
to have an actor with gravitas to bring
this but you again cast the wrong lead
as the female and just go about it which
is so strange to say because like I I
take this all the way back to when one
of my one of my friends is like a huge
Flash Gordon fan right
sat me down to watch Flash Gordon from
night and I'm like this is terrible this
is awful and it came out a couple years
after Star Wars and so I watched Flash
Gordon and my thought was Star Wars so
easily could have become this what's the
difference what's the magic sauce that
made Star Wars this epic that people can
still put on in love and Flash Gordon is
just this thing of its time and I don't
I don't know why the Last Airbender
acting is so terrible and why something
in a very similar vein like a star like
the force awakens or something like that
just feels so much more believable I I
don't have the answer to that because
this acting did feel a little bit like
the prequels where it's like I don't
know what the difference I don't know
what that little magic sauce is I think
director yeah I think it was a few
things for the dialogue was all
Exposition the casting was just so
inauthentic from jump like even though
this is fictional we're talking about
tribes and like like so many different
things that are obviously people of
color and and you see it in the show and
then as soon as it hits the screen and
it's just like I feel bad for the actors
they had an insurmountable mountain to
climb from the gay it's just like it
doesn't fit yeah I mean Our Last
Airbender Ong is supposedly like the the
air Nomads are more like a like a
Buddhist Tibetan kind of thing and and
that's a white kid and then and then
even if you have you have Katara and
Soca and they're the the water folk and
they're more like an Inuit sort of thing
and it's like well that's awesome
so anybody who watched the anime is
instantly like wait what the hell is
going on and folks like me are just
watching this being like
um they cast a lot of white people as
the good guys and a lot of them which I
had an even bigger problem with it than
that like more than the whitewashing
because let's be honest that is like a
Tale As Old As Time Tale As Old As Time
like I I don't even like you you can't
hurt my feelings anymore on white
washing if it was good you know what I
mean like I mean it's not even if it's
good it's like I I know how horrible and
Insidious the idea of this is but it's
almost like I know what you're doing and
as long as you can put an economic
number behind it in both instances where
they take a black actor where it was
previously a white roller one I like
Scarlett Johansson as the best Asian
actor seriously whatever it is Emma
Stone's pretty good yeah
she was they will go to some Bank
ability or marketability concept but the
colorism has no markability right
because like you can't even make the
argument that this was whitewashed for
marketability so that takes that one
away altogether it is basically good
people in light bad people in darkness
like what the heck this is now what's
funny is a movie recently did it again
like we had in the Heights which is
supposed to be this huge Hispanic Story
and there's no dark-skinned Hispanic
characters in The One dark-skinned
person and this is the one that they're
trying to keep out in some way again if
I'm gonna put a positive spin on this
movie
yeah I think that I could sit my niece
and my nephews down yeah and I can and I
and maybe they're young enough to wear
I'm I'm like hey just enjoy this and
don't worry about all of the Hollywood
you know all of the colorism all the
stuff that's going on all the white
washing just sit down and what do you
think of this story I I think that they
can enjoy sequences because I do think
the effects are really good I think the
special effects still hold up I think
the special effects in this are arguably
better than some in in in the prequels
for the most and the Star Wars prequels
but if you if you if you sit down and
watch this the other thing that I have
with this movie is it feels
unnecessarily confusing sometimes yes
where it it's everything else the acting
is so straightforward everybody has this
one note that they're going after but it
does feel like we're kind of muddling a
lot of season one of avatar The Last
Airbender the anime and so I wonder if
the kiddos can follow along with this I
think I don't know if it's a follow
along I think because they knew they had
potentially more installments that they
were already signed up for with the idea
that hey this is around when did The
Avengers happen 2008 um 2012 I mean Iron
Man was two was 2009 okay sorry Iron Man
was 2008 so they're already seeing this
whole like big adventure team ups thing
is in the future like this was not in
the Horizon but it was at least
something they were talking about so I
understand why they were like oh we have
more time we can rush through this one
so long as we get the audience into us
and I think they thought the more we
cover the more the audience will be
happy instead I would have cut this
movie in half in a heartbeat this is a
protection run why don't you just make
it feel that way and then as soon as
you're about to get to Danger cut it off
and I think that's what they were
worried about Steph was there any part
of you as as a fan of the property going
into this that was like okay we we
stumbled a little bit with this one out
of the gate but well course correct we
got two movies left because I had to do
that I I you know after after you
initially see The Phantom Menace and
you're like oh wait what okay don't
worry it's not going to close and you're
like okay revenge of the sit that's
where we get the real good stuff and
then same thing with like a James Bond
movie where uh Casino Royale was great
and then Quantum Visalus was like what
the hell did I just watch I think the
next one's gonna be better though was
there any party that's like okay we're
gonna get a better sequel we're gonna
get our Empire Strikes Back here or were
you just ready to like nope I'm done
maybe I can't I I think maybe I was like
okay I'm excited to see what they do but
it was I was so not into the characters
that it's hard to be excited for that I
feel to your point it's like I thought
Dune did this perfectly yeah they set up
uh the first one so well and then right
before the action they cut it and you're
like I'm in when's the second one coming
out and some people hated that Dune way
that they did that too like this is the
difference between what David Lynch
tried to do with Dune and the difference
between you know what I mean like in a
lot of ways M night was set up the same
way David Lynch was in that respect
where he was not really given the runway
time or amount of material to really
make a compelling film in the way that
he wanted to but I know this is what
happens when you try to please too many
people in the room and the moment is
that you get a movie like this that
doesn't please anybody and I'll say that
again I'll defend a couple of the actors
here again I think Asif Mandy did
everything he could absolutely to have a
little bit of fun here and people like
what but he's from The Daily Show he was
in The Proposal like you you're gonna
cast a comedic actor is this yeah again
funny people can go very dark very quick
yeah right yeah it's where the funny
comes from sorry Darkness lives in there
and and so if you have like a Hans
Gruber yeah you know you you have people
that have with Lincoln and not but
they're also like super villains and I
like some of his stuff and I like that
the moon Spirit ends up just being like
Oh look it's just this little fish thing
so like I like that it's this big thing
no it's just this little thing I think
so much of the war was missed but but
the war that actually hit in this movie
I think does speak to that classical
kind of Joseph Campbell hero with a
thousand faces sort of thing that I
enjoy but so much of it was just miscast
or or mismatched and it felt like a
whole lot of the cannon was just kind of
put in this little ball and it made it
tougher for me to understand than this
movie should have been absolutely I was
going to ask you two about the more
redeeming aspects of it but I do want to
shout out awesome Monday because this is
what's crazy about him is I absolutely
see him doing what Dave Batista is doing
now being a comedian that could really
move over looking at some of the roles
that he's already done yeah like I I can
now like picture back to a random sex in
the city episode that he did and he like
talked about it later because you know
that was back when all he could play was
cab drivers and Tech guys but he was
just like even in those I'm trying to
like add a little bit more where I don't
have to just be this sort of like
archetype of what you would see and an
Indian or South Asian man representing
on screen and this was an opportunity
for that and M night could have done it
and still he like fumbled the bag and I
don't think it was him I think on that
respect especially with the girl like
the girl she came with the money for the
movie so he had to cast her everything
else is literally I think it's just this
was not his movie everything was just
put in place based on what these
producers and the people that had the
rights and had paid for the rights
wanted yeah I I agree because there's
some parts where you just you thought
you had the lore but you didn't like
when we go to the Earth the when the
firebenders are like controlling the
Earth people and they're like
um Aang is like oh just like you're an
extension of the earth like use it it's
right here and I liked that line but
then I remembered that in the series
they're on a steel bow
so they don't have earth like they don't
have that like ability to fight back and
then this it's like it's just right
there like they wouldn't they they
wouldn't if they wouldn't have thought
of that there is a lot of like oh so
this it's it's kind of crazy too when
you make the white kid the one that
teaches everyone it really loses all
effects yeah it really does there
there's something to be said for great
martial arts in movies and there's a lot
of cool martial arts moves in this and
it works well with the effects the
battle scenes play out pretty well but
whereas something I can watch a Van
Damme movie and see great martial arts
and see some some corny acting and some
some just you know cookie cutter plots
and forgive it because it just feels
like such small scale and it doesn't
really matter in the grand scheme of
things this felt like it should have
been bigger this felt like it should
have been meaningful this felt like it
should have been like you know something
that that just gets inside of people in
the mythology and we just carry the
torch forward and make more movies and
when something like this that has this
many uh aspirations attached to it I
think it just it falls harder and it
falls with a thud and I think that the
five percent while I think it deserves
more than that I feel like the Tomato
Meter would have been even less kind to
it had it come out now what's so funny
is everything we're talking four or
three percent yeah what's so funny is
everything that this movie does poorly
the other movie that ripped off its name
and a lot of its uh mythology does
really well it does and Cliff Curtis is
it yes
it's a great one
shout out to one of that out to me like
last week she's like I think like Curtis
is in is in and I was like oh right yeah
he plays the father of the water Nation
uh he went from fire to water baby but
just like Cameron uh just like M Night
Cameron could not really resist the idea
of whitewashing because his wife
totally but like at least James Cameron
I know that the studios were like we
want you to take out some of the hippie
stuff like the nature stuff isn't
working and he's like no that's not true
to the story like we have to keep that
in and I think that's the best part
about the movie and that's the part that
they also deleted out of this sort of
indigenous it was it's literally
indigenous cosplaying and because it's
indigenous cosplaying
in this way that is so crazy is for
everything that Avatar is accused of and
so many things it is absolutely guilty
of the most egregious offender came from
a man called M Night Shyamalan so
everything they accuse Cameron of doing
in a really cynical negative way which
I'm not saying that he doesn't but
everything they're accusing him of we
have a much more egregious example so
that's why I kind of forgive Avatar a
bit more is this movie an example of
where sometimes there are TV shows that
you just simply can't adapt I mean we've
been trying to adapt video games forever
and it looks like maybe the last of us
is the quality show I've seen seven
episodes I can say they got it right
yeah I mean there's been a couple like
Sonic is a fun video game to movie
adaptation but with TV shows sometimes
it works and maybe sometimes you just
have to leave it as a TV series Fair
well I mean they keep trying yeah they
keep trying with anime specifically and
and this show is so like a love for
anime you can tell the way they made it
and like anime fans are like please stop
they did it with Dragon Ball Z Dragon
Ball Z yeah they're doing it they've
done it with so Cowboy bebops this is
the thing some of them do work because I
shouldn't say this the ones that start
as books I think work because Edge of
Tomorrow is based off of manga and
that's amazing and there's a ton of ones
that are based off of mangas that are
amazing I agree but I felt like the
actors watched this and then they kind
of delivered the lines in the way that
the anime does yeah like very One Tone
and it works for anime because it's just
that's the way that the the art is
perceived but for movies it just is like
you gotta change it a little bit I think
you can take the Integrity of the story
but don't like try to be an animated
actor and I think that was Direction
like honestly this is a case where I
just feel the person interpreting The
Source material was not a person that
the source material it's the reason why
apparently Henry Cavill left The Witcher
when you have this rich source material
if the people adapting it don't live and
love it right and they look at it as a
project they need to fix instead of
something that is vibrant and colorful
on its own and their only duty is to be
a shepherd of that
you get the difference it's the
difference between the first six seasons
of Game of Thrones compared to the last
two it's the difference between
um so many different adaptations where
they you know they just don't have their
heart in it all right so brah made a
point and she always wins me over on
something here on this show you're not
getting me over to five percent like I
still feel like this movie deserves
maybe 25 30 but what you said reminded
me of Mortal Kombat the 1995 Classic
Movie that I love all right Paul WS
Anderson's my favorite Paul Anderson
that movie took Mortal Kombat which was
just a fighting game it's just two
people doing this and then they have
moves and whereas that movie injected
some personality into each character
Raiden's having fun Johnny Cage is
having a good time Liu Kang is focused
on avenging his brother they have
backstory here and you feel it you
believe it even if it's silly and
ridiculous you still feel like these are
three-dimensional people
this movie The Last Airbender I think
they were still just doing the Mortal
Kombat thing yeah they're staying in the
video game thing and it's like no no we
need you to become a movie now yeah
you're not still in the Animated World
you need to make it a palatable film and
I think that's why it lost folks like me
who had never seen the anime I'm like
what the hell is going on here this
doesn't feel authentic does it does it
feel too geared towards kids before we
because I want to talk a little bit
about M night and like kind of him
because I feel in this respect like M
night has small kids I think he was
literally making a movie for his like
eight-year-old not realizing that this
audience was more sophisticated than
that I know his daughter dressed up as
Katara and then he was inspired to do
this yeah so I think so but then it's
like why is it so depressing because I
don't think he likes it I think he
really just did it for his kids and then
he didn't know like you know what I mean
like it's it's hard it's almost like
somebody else is in a relationship with
someone and you're trying to come in and
shoot their love story when you don't
even know why they fell in love right
like you don't even know you don't even
know you don't like each other maybe
you've never been in love and you've
definitely never been in love with
whatever they're talking about with that
right you know what I mean like it's
very difficult I think to put it in
there but so you're saying I can't
direct a rom-com is that we all are
trying to say no no yes
no I think I've never gone that far I've
never gone you can direct version of
bros you can direct your cynical love
story absolutely but what I would have
hard time doing is you directing your
widowed father
like I don't think you can make that
kids movie you can't make your safe
passage you can't make it for a kids
movie and also like I I defend anybody
who wants to make something like to
please a family member I think that's
cute and but that's what m night did
with waiting the water too but there was
a bedtime story that he was reading to
his kids and then it like becomes a
movie it's like okay that's yours Raul
Julia his last movie was Street Fighter
not because he thought M bison was going
to be his Legacy character but because
his kids liked it and he knew he was he
wasn't long for this world yeah and he
wanted to make something that was going
to make his kids happy that's awesome
and he did yeah propping him up and
barely able to stand and they still
propped him up and made him look like a
God I love that movie so much for what
they were able to give him in a swan
song because he is giving he's giving
um what's his name in as the Sherwood
um the Sheriff of Nottingham Alan
Rickman Alan Rickman and Sheriff of
Nottingham he is giving it like villain
again Gargamel in his castle realness I
love that kind of villain they don't
need to be in the action but they are in
the action and you know Gargamel has a
little bit of fun on the weekends
exactly I know Gargamel hates the Smurfs
okay I may agree with him sometimes
Gargamel has some fun on the weekends
okay I just hope it's not with the cat
and the lady
it's just a man alone with his cat
that's how you know our directions arise
The Love Story movie if there's a dog in
the middle of it that's how you know
it's directed by Mark well that is very
true
um one of the things I definitely would
talk about we didn't even mention is
because as much as I again will defend
this movie because I I didn't even say
it you can turn off with it as a kid
just turn off with it it's barely 90
minutes a movie has to last a little bit
longer to piss me off in truth it really
does okay you know what I mean like it
didn't waste my time there were still
funny moments good effects I I would
have signed up for Taekwondo immediately
after seeing this movie If I was a kid
and laughable moments and it's pretty I
just think it's really pretty like it's
just like the costumes of the woman that
plays like the queen Empress girl what's
her name I forget her name now um oh and
new or yeah I'm not gonna say it right
because the movie doesn't even think say
it right
um she looks like like something walking
down like the runways of like an
ethereal fantasy show like I love so
much of the look of all of these ones
but there are so many laughable moments
um basically every time
um I just crack UPS stuff they learned
that poor kid into the room with all the
other avatars that have come before him
and they were they tricked him yeah poor
innocent kid oh my God yeah and he had
the reaction of a person you're gonna
die
like I'm just I can't it's not good news
for a kid yeah and he looked like
somebody just look at stuff getting
emotional over losing her favorite
Avatar that really made me choke for a
second
second go right here go right here we
killed our guests ladies and gentlemen
sip I was like oh no
don't worry Steph I just want to let you
know nothing bad happens to Apple the
Flying Bison I will never call myself
funny but on that particular moment I
did have the timing that nearly killed
you you got the that's the ultimate
honor for a comedian is making somebody
shoot liquid out of their nose
[Laughter]
do you know what the subtitle says no
cooing
cooing you know what there's a video on
Tick Tock that Trends right now where
it's like
and I swear it must be from that one
because it's the same thing it's so bad
um any other laughable moment for you if
mondi is purposely laughable but some of
dev's uh villainous stuff is just bad
laughable yes some of the delivery stuff
the whole uh scene where where
um asif's character uh the commander Zao
is is sort of taunting yeah
um this the Zuko and and he's like
what's invite him over for watch and so
you have like all of like his minions
sitting there and they're just watching
and and uh and Zao gets up there and
he's doing his little song of dancing
he's like and this little over
here is basically what he's saying oh my
God like like this little little twerp
he's never gonna live up to what and
then he just storms out and the whole
thing just felt like like a little force
and like if I'm working there if I'm one
of the minions just eating lunch I'm
like I think I should probably go to
with the water folks they seem maybe be
an earth villager it was so funny is he
casts the coolest people to be the fire
people and people you don't think are
cool because first of all even back then
I saw skins so I knew Dev Patel had
Swagger and Mr Steal Your Girl energy
before he grew his hair out yeah that's
when all you other girls paid attention
and I think y'all know which kind of
girls I was talking to black girls have
always been checking on him black and
brown girls have always been checking on
but anyway him awesome like it just feel
like he wanted the Fire Nation to be so
literally fire like literally fire and
it just didn't live up to it quite as
much but what are the other
quote-unquote fire moments because I
will say this the Earth people getting
their Boogie pretty fire to me yeah like
when they were like
like I was living for any time they want
like harness their group Powers but the
Earth people when they were like we
throw on rocks battle scenes martial
arts on ice when we're threatening the
moon spirit and there's this like huge
war going on I love battles with an ice
background that's why I hung out with
Game of Thrones for as long as I did
the tsunami is that your entire moment
yes yes I was like I know that's not
technically fire but I was like okay
okay this isn't the trailer the best
moment okay Elemental anything Elemental
counts also the way the Fire Nation
looks when Dev like like gets his army
out and starts going it felt very Mulan
like like oh you're coming to March like
I I love a good montage like we're
coming to bring the the fight to you
type stuff I also love that one too but
yeah I will say the Earth people bring
in the Ruckus it felt very like
you have made a nice person be mad like
you have made a person who's trying to
exist in pacificity you have made them
be like oh you are definitely going to
find out right now that I was nice as a
kindness I just love them did you notice
when the earth people were like ready to
go they brought up one rock yes but why
one rock there's a whole group honestly
what is
what they do not
they're drawn out like War schemes and
she's like all right we got rid of War
this was not it you know what's really
weird to me also is like the Earth
people have all the like Swagger with no
power this was also where I thought it
was bad casting the Earth people scream
make these black people like they do in
my personal opinion obviously that's not
canon but just based on how he's casting
the rest of this right the Earth people
should obviously be like some form of
indigenous black people based on
everything that they said and they're
like the one people that don't have a
sort of like discernible ethnicity
compared to all the other ones yeah
sorry I'm just like I would have liked
that you know if you're gonna change
like make it that Swagger scene would
have been even better but that's right
that's where I felt it kick rocks
also I think the reason why that was is
again they were found in captivity not
going to say that was wrong but they
could have changed it they could have
changed there's so many like little
things that could have made this whole
thing better but yeah I don't think it
has to be so tied to the Animated Series
but make the changes good make the
changes good you got to please an
audience yeah whether it's the newbies
or it's the hardcores and this right
none of it and hopefully uh hopefully
this new the new spin on avatar The Last
Airbender uh it kind of turns the ship
around and gets the the name back in
there in a positive light apparently the
the new folks are not happy with this
one either because they left that
production too which I don't want to get
into that but it seems like these dudes
have left every production of The Last
Airbender yeah so they're not involved
with this one either but I'm gonna hope
I'm gonna hope and keep your fingers
first but it goes really well
um are you excited for knock at the
cabin are you gonna be checking this one
out open weekend yeah I think I like
Sean Milan like I still like even after
this it's I still think he I like how
he's like this is me yeah and I'm gonna
do my take on things so I'm gonna check
it out I I do love that he's working
with smaller budgets now because I do
believe that uh necessity is the mother
of all great invention and every good
movie we know there was like honestly
Jaws as we know it is because the shark
didn't work well yeah you directors are
best when they have to think their way
out of a box and so the history is
littered with those examples and and you
go all the way back to you know easy
ride or something like that where you
just had to make an independent movie
and I guess we actually got to go across
country to film this thing so I think
that when M night shyaman is put into a
box he finds his way out of it when that
sandbox is huge then it's like you just
have too many toys and you become
Francis Buxton the villain in peewee's
big adventure let's make him a knock at
the cabin I'm so excited to see this
movie I love the visit I defend it after
Earth as much as I could and then this
new you know closing the unbreakable
Trilogy I thought I thought uh glass was
like okay but split was great yeah and
uh and old I thought was a really cool
you know idea yeah I just like that
original stories were being put into
theaters and people when it's the right
director and when the director makes
himself IP like M Night Jordan Nolan QT
and a whole bunch of other people have
done
people show up for them Cinema wins
Cinema wins yeah as I like to say I'm
okay with now people are like this
person I'm gonna show up for even if
they have swings and a misses I like
their style so on that I will always
give a Last Airbender anything from M
Night Shyamalan a bit of a pass that's
gonna wrap it up for us on the movie
talk section we do not have a mailbag
this week because we had plenty to talk
about but before we get out of here
stuff I want you to let us know please
where folks can find you and what you're
working on you can find me on at steps
abroad everywhere and I'm with the World
Girls We're All Over YouTube and patreon
and I do the Sith Council If You're a
Star Wars fan on the Christian Harlow
channel oh giddy up yeah yeah definitely
got to get ourselves I hope they start
making movies again I like Star Wars
movies we have a few I think they need
some time I I would say they need to
take they're cooking honestly I think
everybody needs to just like about
quality
relax I love the Mandalorian the the
baby's cute I like I like the movies we
just got a new Mandalorian trailer which
I'm sure I'll be talking about soon but
I want to make sure besides the
Mandalorian and maybe you know the last
of us which we just talked about
anything you want to recommend to our
audience for them to check out I think
if you were a Last Airbender the series
fan then one animated series I love like
if you're it's more adult but Arcane on
Netflix Kitty it is a steampunk type
animation and it is so sick yeah so that
is what I suggest I was I believe that
Bermuda can actually and that was like
one that people really 11 minute
standing ovation yeah is this true
everybody gets standing ovations at Camp
they do but not always for good reason
anyway that is gonna wrap it up for us
today again if you liked our episode
today talking about The Last Airbender
you want to make some suggestions on
what we should cover next please email
us at RT is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
also be sure to rate review And
subscribe wherever you're seeing this
lovely podcast and if you haven't
already please head over to rotten
tomatoes.com and check out our other
golden tomato Award winners and we'll
see you all next time
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign